okay can i uh good morning everyone and
welcome can i just welcome everyone back
to the council
chamber it's been a long time and a
difficult time
but it's good to see us back in person
so thank you for joining us this morning
um welcome to this meeting of
development control committee a
and we just now need to run through some
domestic arrangements which are
new domestic arrangements that we
haven't heard before can i please ask
members and everyone
present to ensure that you maintain
social distancing
from other people in the chamber at all
times
and in the social areas outside can i
ask you that you please wear a mask
at all times unless you are speaking and
if you're unable to do so
that you use hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distancing at all
times during the meeting and any breaks
please ensure that microphones before
you are muted when you are not speaking
and please do not interrupt other
speakers
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open such as teams chat
and that if you are contacted by a third
party during an application
please bring this to attention of our
legal advisor
if you are intending the meeting to
speak and you persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by
the chair of the meeting and be using
the e-voting system
for those that are able at modern.gov
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting is broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to having been
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council
into the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press
may record film or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded
so just like to run through some
introductions
uh first of all we have ian de prez our
legal
advisor morning inn gemma walker the
area planning manager
robert carmichael who's our governance
officer
and we have vincent pierce and catherine
hale who are the case officers
morning and behind me we have our
monitoring officer
just to make sure we follow the new
rules and others here to
assist with the meeting we also have
ward members at mid-suffolk district
council
uh ward members who are on the committee
may speak on an application but may not
vote
and we also have council helen geek
who's here to speak for an app
on one of the applications so i think on
that note
we'll move on to the agenda uh first
item on the agenda
it's apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any please
thank you chair we don't have any
apologies they could share we do not
have any apologies or substitutions
just before we move on i just need to
run through the fire safety okay
thank you back in the building today
members so
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point
in ipswich town football ground follow
the signs directing you to the fire
exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium the ground floor
areas or walkways
and if you are in the atrium at the time
of the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest
fire exit use the stairs not the lifts
and do not re-enter the building until
you are told it is safe to do so
thank you chair thank you
okay um so no apologies for absence
do we need to receive any declarations
of pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest
by members
no thank you uh any declarations
of lobbying members yeah cassian
yeah yeah i think we've all
all had that yeah okay thank you uh
any declarations of personal site visits
are there any to declare
no thank you um okay so we now need to
confirm
the minutes of the meeting held on the
17th of march 2021.
are there any points of accuracy in the
minutes
if not could i have a proposal please
yeah councilman muller thank you
and do i have a second at cancer field
thank you all those in favor
to adopting those thank you true record
yep sorry chair we have to do the
electronic vote
on that point so uh members if you could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner and go
to the attendance voting tab the vote
will show
in a light blue color
for members who are unable to vote
through the electronic means i will ask
for
your vote momentarily so counselor tim
passmore
four thank you
fred i'm still not logged it's not
logged logged me on yet so
four
just waiting for one more voucher
thank you chair all votes received and
that is unanimously carried
thank you
okay the minutes have been confirmed and
therefore will be signed
um do we need to receive any
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you okay so
we'll move on to the schedule of
planning applications before us we have
two today
first one is dc 1902656
land south of old stock stow market road
in woolpit
and we'll now head over to the case
officer to present
thank you chair with your permission may
i remove my jacket to
present thank you very much
good morning members ladies and
gentlemen as the chairman said here we
have a an outline application
in woolpit comprised two elements
extension to wool pit primary academy
school
in terms of land and erection of 40
dwellings
it is an outline planning application
and all matters
are reserved a bit of housekeeping if i
may
angling water have formerly not objected
so that's a bit of an update for members
the recommendation and section 106 heads
of terms we will be looking at
are on the correction paper that members
have received i will include a
copy of that in my presentation shortly
and we will be presenting a number of
amended drawings
that weren't included in members
information
packs i will describe the amendments in
great detail as we go through
so the paper you should be looking at in
terms of the recommendation and the
section 106
heads should look like that in your pack
agenda item
7a i will go through that
towards the end of the presentation so
that members are fully aware of what we
are expecting by way of section 106
agreement
as always this presentation is
supplementary to the report and it's
only meant as a visual aid
so we're looking at wall pit which under
the adopted
local plan is a local service centre in
the joint local plan
it's a core village so we would expect
development to be focused
within this settlement
woolpit parish council do support the
proposal so on the screen you'll see
comments from december
2020 and updated comments from may
2021
on the other hand we have elmswell
parish council an adjoining
parish who do object and their objection
is based
on their concern that elmswell
children may be expected to attend
schools
in woolpit as a result of this and other
applications
the point i need to make to members this
morning is as described by our
colleagues at
suffolk county council education this is
a matter for suffolk county council and
the education
policy the school in elmswell is being
expanded but there is a finite capacity
in terms of what you're looking at today
this is not something that you should
have regard to we're looking at an
application in wool pit
that provides places in wool pit
geographic context here we have wool pit
flashing on the screen
between ipswich and heads
adjacent to the a14 you can see elmswell
on the other side of the a14
the application site on the screen is
flashing in red
between the wishbone formed by old stone
market road and
heath road on the face of it that
appears to be a site
in countryside but of course members who
are familiar with wool pit
will recall that
permission has been granted and is now
under construction for the site to the
north
that is being undertaken by david wilson
holmes
so this in fact is could be considered
phase two
of a development that is underway
on the screen at the moment you'll see
the phase one layout which
members were very pleased with in terms
of the quality of the layout
what we're looking at here in outline is
the site just to the south
officers have worked hard with the
applicants to come up with
a layout that actually complements
the phase one development and because
this is an outline
planning application members will be
familiar with the
concept that this is an illustrative
layout i think you'll see from my
recommendation we think that
it is of sufficient quality to justify a
condition
requiring reserved matters to be
substantially in accordance with that
layout
and i'll go into more detail as to why
because we've we have certain concerns
around residential humanity and i know
that's something that local residents
and the parish council have concerns
over and i think we've safeguarded the
position
a closer shot so here we have what is
intended to be an extension
to the primary school
here we have open space serving the 40
dwellings
what i would say is in terms of
conditions
if members are minded to grant planning
permission i am suggesting
that the area in red here which is
the school extension site and this
area in red which is the open space you
condition
to to the effect that
it can't be used as part of the
residential site
so you would restrict residential
development to the area edged
yellow my concern would be that if the
school
site was not required technically it is
within the red line
and i think members will want to be
clear that they're not necessarily
granting
permission for residential development
in the red areas
so that's an added safeguard that we are
suggesting to members
constraints relatively unconstrained
site it is outside of the settlement
boundary but the
report describes in detail the policy
position
this is the parameter plan and this is
important because
the red arrow is indicating that
bungalows would be positioned in this
position and this is the area adjacent
to existing dwellings
that is the cause of concern locally
that there could be
a risk of overlooking if the properties
in that location
were anything other than bungalows well
the applicant has agreed that
they would be they're happy to for that
to be conditioned to be bungalows
so that is a good safeguard the green
arrow is
a pedestrian connection that comes
through from the first phase
the blue dash is the vehicular
access and the orange dash is the
footpath connection to the car park
extension
to the health center clinic
just a general shot what we have here
is an indicative mix
drawing and you can see that there is a
broad range of accommodation
now i know i believe that uh councillor
mansell and councillor geek
are anxious to understand how that can
be delivered
if this is an outline application
and what i'm going to suggest in the
next slide is depending on how members
feel about the layout there are certain
elements that we could control by
condition
so for example on this slide the overall
mix is
as shown on the screen that is a mix
that
our own strategic housing team are
comfortable with
normally on an outline application if
you do not condition
mix it's too late when it comes to
reserved matters
so i just remind members that if mix is
an issue we should deal with that
during the debate and you decide how you
want to
tackle that question the next point is
what are the story heights well
at the moment we have no indication of
story heights
in the application if members were
thinking
in this location two stories might be
the ideal maximum
you should consider conditioning that if
you are minded to grant
planning permission if you were to say
no more than three
the choice is yours but it is something
we could legitimately
deal with today by way of condition
the blue edge shows exactly where the
bungalows
ought to be and should be and i'm
suggesting if members are minded to
grant plenty of [ __ ] we actually
condition it
so that that is the location where
bungalows must be provided
we also have on this slide the location
of affordable houses and you can see
that they are pepper potted again
we could by conditioning the reserve
matters to
be in substantial accordance with the
indicative drawing actually direct the
location
for affordable housing at reserve
matters if that's something members
wanted to do
so what about access well we're going to
look at pedestrian and cycle access
first the green dot on the right
is a segregated footweight cycle way
that will be
provided within phase one that would
then
extend into what we might call phase two
which would give pedestrian cycle access
to the playing field if it was
taken up by the county council and then
on
to the gp car park extension
cars and vans and other vehicular
traffic would come in through the
existing access that has been created
on old stone market road to serve phase
one
so you would come down through the
estate in phase one
and simply extend into this phase
that connection does not extend into
the gp car park extension we have
deliberately avoided that to ensure that
the pedestrian access
is unencumbered by vehicular movements
and of course you can also get to the
car park extension
through that alternative route the car
park is not part of this application but
i know that it is something that is
locally well received
local people are expecting to see that
car park arrive very shortly we do have
a planning application for it
and i thought it would be wise to
include it so that members could see how
this
proposal connects to that element
there's another closer shot so the car
park would have two pedestrian
access points one from the east one from
the south
with and obviously there will be
pedestrian access to the north but that
would also
be the vehicle axis so in terms of
connectivity
this phase two element combines with
phase one to provide
really good connectivity through that
site
back into woolpit and of course the
surgery
and the school
access in the you'll see on the bottom
left hand corner that's the school
extension site that would be served
potentially with a
vehicular access and pedestrian cycle
access
if it was taken up by suffolk county
council
that is the existing access that's been
created by david wilson homes on old
stone market road and that would
be the point of access for this next
phase if members were minded to grant
permission
so let's look in more detail at the
question of residential amenity because
this is the one that has some
the parish council local residents are
most keen to see that we've dealt with
satisfactorily so on this slide the
blue ang wedge
is the viewing angle we're looking back
towards heath road so you can see
to the left is the school to the right
is the health center and in the middle
there are houses some of those are
very close to the boundary so the issue
is
clearly how will the amenity of those
residents be impacted by development on
that boundary
well on this slide what we have
shown is the position of the bungalows
is such
that they would be immediately adjacent
to existing dwellings there is no
prospect of overlooking from first floor
windows
because there won't be any first floor
windows and we can condition and remove
permitted development
so that somebody couldn't then put rooms
in the roof at a later date
and again that might be something that
members want to think about so i am
satisfied
that we have dealt with the issue of
residential immunity in terms of the
risk of overlooking
that is something that the applicant has
agreed as well so there won't be any
issue between us where my members might
be minded to
grant permission just so you've got an
idea of
what the adjacent properties look like
the photograph on the top left
are the houses in the little muse to the
top
of the slide on the right and then the
attractive brick cottages are the heath
road
frontage again there are the shots so on
the left you see the
existing fence and you can see some of
the houses on the
left ecology again
our colleagues at place services have
looked at this proposal and they are
satisfied with the
statements that have been received so
far we are
obviously going to condition uh
ecological mitigation as a reserved
matter some members want to see
that fine detail were you to grant
planning permission outline stage
that would come in in later but
obviously this is a is a connection
between urban woolpit
and the rural area around it so we have
a chance to create some
interesting and useful wildlife
corridors green corridors
as tendrils going out in the countryside
i know that there has been some concern
loki that this
rather lovely tree in the corner of the
gp
surgery site may be affected by this
development we are satisfied
that it will not be harmed by the
development
we do have a tree protection condition
in place we do have our
cultural surveys in place this tree and
all the other trees to be retained would
be
protected in accordance with british
standards so if essentially that's
harris fencing
secured so that nothing can bump into
dumpers and little trucks can reverse
into the tree
and it avoids compaction of the soil
around the
the trunk in terms of section 106
agreement
we are getting the full 35 percent
affordable
housing there will be a contribution
of 34 000 towards cycle link and
members familiar the area will know the
importance of the
cycle and pedestrian connection between
elmswell and and wall pit
the residential scheme by hopkins
in the north village is providing a
connection to the roundabout
on the a14 and suffolk county council
are currently looking at how that gets
extended into
woolpit we are elsewhere apologies we
are also securing financial
contributions from developments in
elmswell
to extend that that link
the school transfer land would be
included in the 106.
there would be a financial contribution
towards the cost of
extended places for primary children 184
572 that's been agreed with suffolk
county council
we also get contributions towards
secondary school transport
and preschool provision so on that
basis and with the added suggested
conditions
safeguarding the school transfer site
and open space site preventing it from
being used for residential development
as part of this permission we are
recommending two members that
subject to that 106 being satisfactorily
completed
the chief planning officer is able to
grant conditional planning permission
thank you chair thank you
thank you very much okay questions from
members
yes counselor oops uh
thank you chairman just a question you
mentioned earlier about the
stories number of stories of houses now
i
know in the middle of woolpit there are
some that are probably three maybe even
four stories from what i remember
what is the general street scene in the
vicinity and also
for the adjacent new development so that
we can make sure it fits
so we can therefore make a decision
please on the number of stories as you
suggested thank you councillor passmore
the phase one is predominantly two-story
the prevailing character in heathrow is
two-story i would suggest that
two-story would be complementary to the
existing character of this
immediate locality
thank you chair um thank you very much
um vincent for that presentation
i've got a couple of questions if i may
um
with regards to the cycle link
um could you just um confirm what the 34
thousand pounds will deliver
will will it deliver a cycle link
actually from woolpit all the way to
elmsworld
station or is it just part of that um
secondly this school extension site
um there's been there's various
references to
being extension to the school um land
a playing field um and i just
wanted some clarification on exactly
what that land is likely to be used for
and secondly there's already a new
school site
on another application in woolpit so
why are we having a um this extension
site if there's already a new school
site
planned and and can you explain the um
differences there please and the third
one
if i may is just with regard to warpit
neighborhood plan
um i understand it's at its closing
stages as it were
um so presumably carries reasonable
weight
um and if this is outside the settlement
boundary i know that
woolpit's i understand got various
policies in relation to that if you
could just clarify those thank you very
much
thank you very much councillor eben the
first point i would make
is the 34 000 contribution is just that
it is a contribution it goes into the
pot and suffolk
county council will help uh deliver the
connection through to ellsworth using
that money and other monies
that it is collecting so it isn't for a
specific section
of that path the
school extension site you are absolutely
right the largest site in berry road
when granted outline planning permission
did include
a site for a new primary school we have
the reserved matters for the residential
element in at the moment
what suffolk county council asked for
was this particular extension site in
the event they needed it
i suppose as a sort of a backup plan
that if that school for whatever reason
didn't happen
there would be space here to expand the
primary school in
heath road in terms of the section 106
we would ensure that the
time available for suffolk county
council to take up that site was
sufficient
for them to know what is happening to
the
the new site off bury road to the north
so if it wasn't required then clearly
it wouldn't be a school extension site
suffolk county council wouldn't take up
that
that option because the new sky school
would have been
provided in terms of
the neighborhood plan you are absolutely
right councillor eben to say that
the world pit neighborhood plan is is
reaching its
its end point in terms of the
referendum we have a policy in there
wpt2
which sets out criteria for
development you'll recall that actual
allocations were removed from the
neighborhood plan but wpt2 actually
provides us with the criteria
this scheme satisfies the criteria
for development even though it is
outside of the village envelope
wpt5 was the policy
for this site but you'll recall the
inspector commented on that and said the
fact that it had been taken out
along with all the other allocations
does not preclude suffolk county council
from
reserving this for school purposes and
it doesn't preclude planning permission
being granted for
development so in terms of
why is this site acceptable if it is
outside of the
settlement boundary it is a site that
was in
was taken out but actually in terms of
the tests the normal tests for
sustainable development
it fits all of those it is adjacent to
existing development
it is adjacent to the settlement
boundary it is adjacent to a a
significant development that is
currently under construction
we are satisfied that it doesn't pose
any issues within the mppf
and doesn't um present any unfortunate
precedence for
development outside of settlement
boundaries in other villages
and we are comforted by knowing that the
parish council do support this proposal
it's something that they have
backed for quite some time thank you
thank you did you want to come back
thank you um yes if i may come back so
just to be absolutely clear if
we may not need that extension for the
school
for the school and we that will
we will know that in some a year two
years
time and if we don't need it will it
just become a space
a a wild open space for the use of
villagers and so on or will it just
become an extra bit of playing field so
thank you thank you
councillor eben that is right suffolk
county council as the education
authority will decide whether they need
it or not in due course
if they don't require it because the new
school has come on stream
it would revert back to the landowner as
agricultural
land what we're doing is with the
suggested condition is
in safeguarding the position that it
couldn't come back
under the outline as residential
development
in terms of what is reasonable in the
planning sense
if it is currently agricultural land
remaining agricultural land is perfectly
acceptable
but we have safeguarded position because
nobody wants
residential development through the back
door if
in due course somebody did want to use
it for residential it would have to come
into an application and you would judge
it on its merits
at that point thank you
thank you next caster matterson
thank you chad yeah i've got i've got
several but if i could just deal with
two
um the police services ecology page 22
um but they um
if looking at the detailed papers on
page 80
they do reference their their um um
submission um on um october 2019 but i
couldn't find that in the papers
so i was wondering what that actually
had to say and the other one
was um regarding that tree that you
highlighted
of particular value can we guarantee
that there will not be underground
utilities
taken within the tree protection area
please
i'm aware of an unfortunate uh other
example recently um
where that did happen thank you
councillor if i take your second point
first
that is a a very good point and it is
something we can
control by condition um
i would suggest something along the
lines of
service runs have to be agreed with the
local planning authority where these
could
prejudice the retention of trees
in that way if somebody wanted to dig a
trench right past that tree we at least
have some influence to say no you can't
do that you have to divert that to avoid
that
tree i think that would give us the
protection
you seek because ordinarily you're right
we don't have that control and then
somebody finds out that
roots have been severed to put a sewer
pipe in or electric cable
so that is perfectly acceptable in my
view particularly this is an outline
application you've alerted any
prospective purchasers to
don't go and start thinking you can put
service runs straight through that
hedge or past that tree in terms of the
comments from place services i don't
have access to
that document at the moment but whether
or not my colleague
ms walker can dip into the file
what i would say is though that the
updated comment
police services are happy but they're
suggesting we fully condition all
ecological matters
so what we may need to be uh
conditioning things
which are in that other paper so we'll
come back to that later
and um and again with the tree yes
please can we
deal with that at the end of the um
debate
please well that that will be for us to
determine what we want
well that's my request to the committee
at this stage thank you
thanks uh councilman
uh thank you chair um um slide 20
a and b um you were showing the uh
pedestrian vehicular access
through the um proposed development but
you made no mention
of the footpath link
to the south west where it meets the
public right-of-way network
it was cut off the bottom of your map on
slide 20.
so could you please clarify whether that
is going to be available or not
absolutely categorically it will be
available apologies
for cutting off the corner of the map
i'm sure i could actually find the
drawing but there is a
there is an arrow on the drawing that
says connection to path so
apologies can i come back
perhaps it might be helpful um obviously
i know exactly where it is but
maybe you could point it out to the rest
of the committee uh when they come to
their or before they come to their
deliberations so they know what i'm
talking about
it might not be clear to everybody else
in the room absolutely
perfectly fair request thank you
okay casterfield
thank you just two points
one i was going to question public realm
talk on page 23 about a development of
this
size 190 houses i thought it was
40. that are they on the right
development i was going to question
whether we uh
addressed the play provision but i know
you say that's a
reserve matters issue so nevertheless
are they on the right development
the second thing is looking at page 29
power
4.1 you talk about provision of the mppf
r-72 and talking about large numbers of
houses
i always thought that meant some
thousands of houses not
40. so are we um
misleading ourselves by considering
paragraphs that don't
actually apply thank you
thank you councillor field there is
the public realm comments appear to be
related to an amalgamation of phase one
and this phase you are quite right this
is a scheme of
40 houses we aren't requesting any
specific
play facilities within this part of the
development because they are provided
in the phase one part of the scheme
in terms of the reference to
the mppf this is a small scale
residential development
even though it technically is a major it
doesn't fall into the large scale major
category so apologies if that has
in any way misled the committee to
correct it just to confirm it is a major
application but is small scale
comprising up to 40 dwellings thank you
councillor
thank you anyone else wish to come in
that i've missed
no okay so we'll move on um so thank you
for that
uh we now move to public speaking uh we
don't have a representative of the
parish but we do have
an extra response from willpower parish
council that obviously has been included
in the table of papers
and we don't have an objector or
supporter either so now
now ask the applicant neil waterson to
speak mr wilson you have three minutes
please
uh thank you chair members uh thank you
for the opportunity to speak to you
this morning the application before you
today is a high quality
sustainable landscape design led scheme
which has been brought forward following
extensive engagement with your officers
suffolk county council wallpaper parish
council
ward members and the local community the
proposal forms an extension to the 120
new homes granted reserve matters last
year to the north
and is a natural infill site being
surrounded on three sides by development
construction of the phase one site is
now well underway with the first new
homes
due to be completed shortly the site is
in a sustainable location with wallpaper
designated as a key service centre
in both the adopted and emerging local
plans and has good access to a range of
facilities within the village
the scheme is in full accordance with
the draft neighborhood plan policy wpt2
location and scale of new housing
developments with the neighborhood plan
due for its referendum soon
as a result the application continues to
have the full support of the paris
council
as highlighted by their comments sent to
the committee parish council support
reflects the extensive engagement
undertaken both before the submission of
the application
and during the progress of the
application the design of the scheme has
been informed by comments from
local residents the parish council local
ward members as well as other consultees
and stakeholders
and in particular particular note the
scheme has been amended
incorporating bungalows and landscaping
to enhance the immunity relationship
with adjoining properties on the site's
western boundary
and the schemes housing mix includes a
higher proportion of bungalows and two
or three bed
market homes exceeding the requirements
of neighbourhood plan policy wpt6
all technical issues heritage landscape
ecology
drainage and utilities have been
comprehensively addressed and the scheme
is readily deliverable
this high quality sustainable scheme
accords with the mppf
and the development plan taken as a
whole and has the support of the parish
council
will deliver new homes to meet local
needs including affordable housing and
new bungalows
land for the future expansion of the
village primary and preschool
providing flexibility to meet future
needs
provision of new green infrastructure
and biodiversity enhancements
and enhance pedestrian and cycle links
particularly between the school and the
health center
we believe these will provide lasting
bella benefits for the village
and we therefore hope that you will
follow your office's recommendation
and resolve to approve this application
thank you and
happy to answer any questions from
members
thank you very much members any
questions yes counselor eben
thank you chair thank you very much for
that um
just with regards to um landscaping um
you you mentioned it in your three
minutes but there doesn't seem to be
on the um maps that we've got in our
papers there doesn't seem to be
much landscaping um identified
um have you considered more landscaping
on the the
what would effectively be the northeast
side and then the north the south
west side by the bit behind the heath
road houses
thank you very much um well we did
specifically
um amend the the layout to incorporate
additional landscaping along the
boundaries with the properties
uh the back onto the site from oakland's
that that was one of the changes
undertaken following discussion with uh
local members and officers um to to help
to protect the immunity of those
properties
and obviously with the requirement that
the
reserve matters would need to be in
substantial accordance with the layout
that will need to be incorporated it's
also a principle that's captured on the
parameter plan
which is for determination as part of
this planning application
as well
thank you any other questions council
failed
i noticed there's quite an extensive
input from the
police on this application talking about
uh
surveillance and i don't know provision
of watchtowers at the corners of the
site or whatever
and has that been taken into account in
an appropriate sort of way those
comments
um as part of the design of the scheme
we've tried to ensure
that all residential properties are
fronting onto
the public realm and that there is good
overlooking of the
public realm in all areas it's always a
balance
in designing schemes to ensure different
things are taken into account
we also have to adhere to the county
council parking standards of course
which aren't necessarily fully aligned
with some of the police
comments but um obviously there's
further scope to pick up some of the
detail in terms of
um boundary treatments and things like
that at reserve matters stage as well to
ensure that some of the very detailed
comments from the police are taken into
account at that stage
thank you anyone
else if i've missed any hands nope
okay thank you very much okay we'll now
move on to the ward members
and we have two ward members uh
councillor helen geek and councillor
sarah mansell who would like to go first
councilman uh
thank you um it's always refreshing when
a parish council
uh is in support of a major planning
application
uh traffic from this site does not need
to go through the heart of the village
in order to access the a14
and the other main destinations and this
site does seem like a natural extension
to the earlier application
which is currently being built out uh
the applicant and agent
have been working with both our planning
officers parish council
and and we've had several meetings with
them uh to try
and mitigate the concerns that have been
raised by this application
um i think we've secured the bungalows
and appropriate boundary treatment along
the sensitive western boundary with
existing dwellings on heath road uh
important things from my point of view
are the pedestrian and cycle links
between the development site and
heathrow's
otherwise it's a very long way round to
go via old stone market road and people
will be tempted to resort to motor
vehicles
the access via the health center should
be secured by other planning
applications i
i think i don't think it's part of this
application uh and there will be access
to the school
but it is still vital to ensure that the
connection to the public right-of-way
network to the southern tip of the site
is also secured the application for the
extension to the school site has now
been muddied by the granting of the 300
homes to the east berry road with
site for a proposed new school the
county council seems now to be
backtracking about whether they still
want this extension site here
yet that part of the application was the
main reason
that the parish council gave support to
this application
and it is a great pity that the advice
given by south prevented any
representative from
parish council from attending today
now this school extension is in the
balance
because the second school site um which
is on the other application
um uh you know
the whole education um of the children
of both elmsworld and woolpit is
is is is confusing uh and it is the most
ridiculous and unsustainable
proposal to educate elmsworth's primary
school children in warpit
unfortunately that's not up for
discussion as part of this application
but the county council need to offer
more surety for this school extension
site
and i think it's also a shame that there
isn't a representative from the south
county council
developer contributions or whatever
their department is called uh here today
to explain that to the committee
if this land is not used for education
purposes then
no doubt we'll see further planning
applications down the line
everything is now all too uncertain
i was disappointed when i read the
papers to see that the housing mix has
not been conditioned as part of this
outline application
the agent had some correspondence with
msdc back in november 2020 which stated
that they would be happy to have such a
condition
so i hope that the committee will be
forthcoming with the condition about the
housing mix
as was outlined in the um presentation
this would also be in compliance with
walpit neighborhood plan policy wpt6
which i don't think vincent mentioned
which was a housing mix policy in the
woolpit naval neighborhood plan
so i would urge you to add this as a
condition if you are minded to approve
today
although not a material consideration we
are all aware that the applicant will be
passing this site onto a third party for
the build-out
and this will provide more certainty to
the community that we're going to get
what we see on the plans today thank you
thank you very much councillor geek
thank you chair um councillor mansell is
right to say that
wall pit parish council have supported
this scheme from the outset
this is partly due to the work put into
consultation by the applicant and our
officers
but it is largely because it was thought
to be delivering an extension to the
existing school
this expanded school is strongly
supported by the village
residents do not want a second school to
be built they do not want to split the
village into two educationally
and for different reasons elmsworld
parish also it's well known that they do
not
want that new school to be built um
we're currently in woolpit going through
negotiations with another developer in
the village regarding reserved matters
to a large
uh outline consent and here we've
discovered that if you don't get it
absolutely right at outline stage you
have very little scope to change things
later
now because of the school extension
we're not fighting the principle of
development here when i say we i mean
residents in the in the parish um
and we can we can have time to look at
the detail which as
um as vincent said has been fought hard
for by officers and forward men
by board members and by the parish
council um
unfortunately a lot of the detail we've
only seen in slides today they weren't
included in the documents on
the website nor in the committee report
so please come i urge the committee to
follow
our officer's advice today and
conditioning and at the risk of being
boring can i just remind you very
quickly the bungalows should be
conditioned where they were on the
presentation slide 17.
you i don't think we have that in the um
in the committee report and the printed
papers the building heights should be
conditioned to two stories maximum
the location of the affordable housing
must be in the slides as today
particularly slide 26a
slide eight of the committee report that
you have in front of you in the printed
papers is based on an
out-of-date plan the trouble with all
these lovely negotiations is they
produce so many iterations of the plan
nobody seems to have any idea which one
they're using the up-to-date plan you
can see in slide 11
those pale blue blocks are the
affordables including the bungalows
behind mountain house
the housing mix again as in the slide
today i think it was slide 18.
this matches the aspirations as has been
said in woolpit's neighborhood plan
wpt6 um another one
uh as councilman mansell has pointed out
please could we
ensure that the footpath to the
southeast links into the public footpath
network
to condition the school extension site
so that it can't be used as residential
development
is a great idea that's the first i've
heard of it today i don't expect that it
will protect this area from future
development but as you say by the back
door it would be good to stop that
and lastly as councillor madison has
suggested that service runs should be
placed away from that lovely oak tree
in the corner of the health centre car
park it would be a pity to protect that
just for it to die for other reasons um
and can i just
lastly uh say um
how sensible it is that councilor
mansell has pointed out that it will be
passed on to a third party to
to develop we have to make sure that
that we build
um we build into
[Music]
we build in requirements to have this
hard-fought detail
maintained thank you
okay thank you very much uh council phil
do you have a question
at the stage
of the ward members yes
it was just the issue of schooling
you should get trapped into the debate
but i find the
county position obscure to put it mildly
i was going to ask whether the board
members have actually had more detail of
the county's strategic plans for
schooling in this particular area
which it seems somewhat critical to the
decisions we made
you've been in discussions with them um
in terms of
education policy i believe
suffolk county council are expecting
the new school to be provided but of
course
as councillor mensah said we don't have
a representative
from the educational authority here and
because of the sensitivity of the
issue between wool pit and elmsweil i
would not
wish to set a hair running that actually
is is
the wrong hair so i guess my answer
chair is it is a matter for suffolk
county council i do understand the
sensitivity
but that isn't something as the planning
authority we're here to consider
today thank you
thank you yeah i've got two questions
first question
for councilman mansell um that there's
um something made in in the papers of
the
um that the upcoming
uh sustainable um travel linkage
between the two villages um
in your experience of from training
children to um
to cycle um
[Music]
realistically five-year-olds um
but attending the primary school at what
age would you think
um children will actually cycle the two
miles
if we get the linkage completed
um i can't answer for the rest of
society
i'm afraid i certainly cycled my kids to
school
when they were four they may have been
in a trailer
um and they were cycling on their own at
probably about six or seven
with an adult um i can't and people
thought i was mad so i certainly can't
ask for answers for the rest of the
population
um my children would be cycling but my
children are now in their twenties so
they won't be going to primary school in
warfare
thankfully
could i just put a different um
slant on that that um i have a child
with autism spectrum disorder
he has very poor balance and he's never
learned to ride a bike and he's now 15.
so so at least one of my children could
not and therefore the whole group
could not um and i think it's probably
sensible i mean these anecdotes are all
very well
but i think it's probably sensible to
think about um
at eight the government expects you to
be able to
to cope with three miles rather than two
doesn't it
so i think that any child from five to
eight definitely
you know it's very unusual that they'll
be they'll be cycling like councillor
mansell's family
above eight it's very unusual that like
my family we won't be cycling
yeah we i think we can give multiple
examples can't we um
but but that but the the the the three
versus two is set
yeah did you want to come back yes i
think sorry the
let's just have the case officers come
back then we'll come back to you
chad i just remind members of the slide
that we presented towards the beginning
of my
presentation where suffolk county
council have
described the expansion that is occur
will occur
in elmswell of school places
there is at the moment with that you
they haven't reached capacity
so what we're looking at in amsterdam is
a future situation and obviously if more
development happens in elmspal
pressure builds but at the moment
it isn't the issue that perhaps has been
suggested this morning
if the county council's comment is
correct
we can go to that slide if we need to no
we'll go to council madison first
it's a planning question and and it
relates
it right to the same issues really um
are we are we able um to
to actually link the two uses on this
site
such that we that the housing only goes
ahead if the school expansion
is taken up
i would say that is unreasonable because
i think we have established that it is a
sustainable
development in a sustainable location
and would pass the
mppf tests of sustainability
okay so we're gonna
one more question questions for the
world oh sorry i do apologize next then
cancer we'll come back to you cancer
field
um
thank you very much thank you chair um
it's actually
um will be a question for the officer
driven from what the
ward members have said um the in the
school
places there's 30 in the county's
response
there are 34 places that would have
arisen from the hawley park
um application which was refused
on appeal so that is not going to happen
so we are 34 places
short in the area and i'm i too am very
disappointed given the school is a very
key thing
that we haven't got somebody here from
the infrastructure team to discuss that
and i also wanted to ask about the
parish council's um
representation here today
apparently they've been given different
legal advice about attending meetings
than we have
they've been given advice from salk not
to attend meetings and we've been given
advice
to attend meetings so how can we
question the parish council
if they aren't here thank you
well i think we'll go to the monitoring
office on that i mean the government is
clear that
meetings need to take place um could you
comment on
the fact that parish councils aren't
able to attend
so um can you turn the mic on
sorry and take my mask off yeah so
um i can't comment on the advice that
selk has given to
um parish councils the government
regulations say
state that um council should
um look to arrange meetings after the
17th but obviously
we have a statutory obligation and legal
obligation to consider planning
and that falls within the regulations
that was released on april 12th which
says
if there are legal reasons we can hold
meetings so
they're you know um as i say for
parishes
they can hold meetings it doesn't say
you can't
but the advice was they should hold them
after the 17th of may
i have to say and i know we're going
back to hearsay but i've got three
parish councils next meet that are
meeting physically
so i know they are starting up again
okay any other questions yes cancer
field
yeah sorry to return to the school one
but i think it is vital
um i certainly found the figures in the
paper confusing although i think the
officer
quoted some more numbers this morning or
had a slide with more numbers
it's totally unclear to me whether the
county actually requires
both this primary expanded or not
expanded and this other
school side that's that's suggested
and whether it's just trying to play
this for maximum financial gain or
whether there is really
an issue of pupil numbers because they
didn't quote existing pupil numbers
to us and whatever you know is clearly
their responsibility get clearly it's
irresponsible to give
permission for housing where the the
infrastructure
the school infrastructure doesn't match
so
have they given that guidance
that is something that i don't have the
answer
to um what will i have the figures that
were presented at the start of this
i can't speak for our colleagues at
suffolk county council
okay thank you right yeah councilman
sorry just returning again to the school
we we've heard that
if the county council don't require the
land it will return
to the original owner um i'm interested
in time scales here in that
the school is dependent on future demand
do we know
at what point that transfer will happen
and will it happen
to um a you know as yet unidentified
developer
um it seems to be a very um
messy situation and i i do have concerns
that in three years time we'll be sat
here discussing
development on that bit of land so
is there a time scale that the county
council got to make a decision
about whether they need that land or not
i think the answer is to some degree in
the gift of this
committee obviously in terms of the fine
detail of the section 106 agreement
there would be a
an element that we might call a sunset
clause i.e
if it isn't taken up by the county it is
returned
but you could suggest two years five
years
ten years that is in the gift of this
committee so if you want to direct us as
officers
in our negotiation that is something you
could do
is it within the gift of this committee
to dictate that that land is returned to
the parish rather than the
original that is something i have
considered and my answer
i think would have to be in terms of the
test of reasonableness
this proposal actually includes
provision of open space we are only
looking
at 40 dwellings so the open space that
is being provided for
recreational purposes meets your
standards
to secure the field for additional
open space on the back of 40 dwellings i
suspect there will be some resistance
from the
own landowner and the applicant on the
reasonable ground that it wouldn't pass
the
civil test of being reasonable you would
be asking for more than
is eligible based on the scheme of 40
dwellings
unfortunately it is something i thought
about it is something i floated
but i had to i had to think actually
if this was pushed we would probably be
on very weak ground in terms of
the test of reasonableness but it is
something i looked at
can i just come back to the point around
the time scale then because
i mean obviously a lot depends on you
know future families moving to the area
i mean you know these things aren't
something that happens tomorrow
uh you know you the planning for schools
is something that's very far
forward thinking so you know what is a
reasonable time frame i mean two years
is certainly not reasonable i would
thought five is tight
uh you know because i mean planning goes
on far into the future
i would always err on the side of
caution and i would go for
10 to 15.
okay i think we've got no other hands up
so we'll now move into
debate uh so members over to you uh
we've heard
um we've obviously had uh written
representations we've heard from the
ward members we've heard from case
officer councilman you want to start
uh thank you very much chair it's been a
very interesting to listen to
everyone's comments on this um
personally i'll be
prepared to recommend approval of this
application
subject to all the conditions that the
case
officer mentioned earlier for example
two-story maximum
for the houses the condition regarding
the location of bungalows i think that's
very important to consider the
residents already living in heath road a
condition of the location of the
affordable housing either the housing
mix
also a condition about permitted
development
so that in the future that
residents could not put windows in their
roofs
roof space etc so they wouldn't look
over the properties on heath road
and also i totally agree with councillor
matheson's comment that a condition
should be made
regarding service runs not prejud
prejudicing
the oak tree and the other trees on the
site
and i also would accept the condition
regarding the school
and i do agree with what chair you
mentioned there we have to look at the
future and i think this should be at
least a minimum of 10 years
so on that basis i will be happy to
recommend approval
thank you chair so are you proposing
that
yes yeah thank you council uh thank you
chairman i'm going to
second councilman i think it has been a
very interesting debate and i do agree
with all those conditions
um we are talking about 40 houses the
fact that the parish council is in favor
i think is important and as someone said
it's actually quite refreshing to find
that in a planning application
um my office has said it is sustainable
um and
i do agree with them in this case and um
so therefore i'm happy to support it as
regards the timeline
um i'm not trying to split hairs here by
the time these applications
actually get going construction
sometimes it does take a couple of years
i know you've got to come back for
reserve maths and so on i would just
think perhaps at this stage
we need to perhaps say 12 13 years
maybe 15. only because we're trying to
be pragmatic as you rightly say chairman
planning schools is a long protracted
process and always controversial
as we see today but we do need to be
pragmatic and i am
just suggesting if a councilman would
would agree with that perhaps edging up
to the 15 years from there might be more
sensible
on the grounds that it has to be
reasonable and that's not me trying to
duck the issue we've got to make sure it
works and we don't get into a tangle
later so
in summary chairman i'm very happy to uh
second councillor
mueller's proposal thank you thank you
uh next up was cancer field
yes i was gonna suggest i seconded it
but that seems to have gone
um i mean much much of this has been
said the the
the parish council support is important
clearly most of the criteria seem to
suggest that we should uh approve this
um with with the list of uh conditions
that uh
councilman muller suggested i do find
the
the education issue a significant
concern
if nothing else for certainty of people
the parents involved and the the
population of warped at the moment
it does seem that um
the county just seems reluctant to make
decisions on these issues
and give clarity even if that clarity
is if x gets approved we'll do why and
if if zed gets approved we'll do i or
whatever it is that that
um i certainly know in
in in my area liking them
schools have been sites have been
proposed and schools have been discarded
they've decided not to take those
schools up to the great disquiet of the
people who've purchased houses on the
basis and school is going to appear
and we've all heard the concerns about
uh pupils
having to travel from elmsville to wall
pitch so there are there is a lot of
concern
and we're just not um giving a clear
consistent
coherent set of plans to address those
issues to my view
you know having said that most of the
matters are
perfectly satisfactory so i'll certainly
support to the
the application but with an extended
wings that we should
do better on some of our decision
processes thank you
thank you council field uh next up is
councillor matheson
you're next time thank you yeah i have
to gently
correct councillor passmore that we've
not had a debate we've asked quite a
number of questions about the school but
we've absolutely not had a debate
um yet and i must say i'm very
very uncomfortable with this this school
situation i
i know mr pierce wants us to to
say oh well it's it's not a matter for
this committee whatever but
the public expects us i think
particularly the district which does the
majority of
land-use planning um expects us to
deliver good
planning and good good development and
and
putting the school in the wrong village
is it just doesn't
it's just not good planning at the end
of the day
it is it is not beyond the bounds of
possibility that the county would
purchase a site in the correct village
and and set aside the offer
of of school land i mean remember in
thurston we we were offered two
two school sites which was one more than
was needed
and um got into a bit of a muddle on
other matters
and it's just it's not it's not the
right answer
and and you know and all right mr
pearson
it's unreasonable to withhold and link
this by and link the two together
the two issues together but really
we ought to be we ought to be doing that
because again that is
that's actually sensible sensible
planning
um we've got loads and loads of houses
being developed in woolpit
do we need another 40
not urgently um
[Music]
we're told that the parish has supported
this particularly on the basis
that that it will provide the extension
of the school
that that wool pit needs um
which is not the same thing as providing
another school for
for a different village so i i really i
can't support this as it is i
i just wish that the officers could
could show us a way in which we can
actually get
deliver sensible planning but i'm not
can't support it
thank you councilman eben
[Music]
thank you very much chair um i too have
got grave concerns about this
school site um i just feel that
the it's very poor service from the
school's infrastructure team at the
county
in that you know we should have
consistent planning
as to what is needed you know we've been
talking about housing numbers for years
you know how it is not possible to
actually
forecast and agree where schools
sites should be or extensions to schools
should be in the villages where those
pupils live
it is beyond me um so i'm very concerned
that this site that we will sit here in
a few years time and be coming across
a site to fill in that piece of land
as an agriculture use i mean if it goes
back to agriculture use i mean how
they're even going to access it
you know drive tractors across the
estate i'm i'm not sure
um so i'm very concerned about the
the lack of proper future planning for
this school
site and any any detail from the county
council
and it does concern me that
locals have supported this they
supported the previous application
because the community benefits would
give to um
provide a health health center car park
and they would support this one because
the school would be extended but if the
school was not going to be extended
what do they get another 40 houses with
no extension to their local
primary school for that's been there
since some victorian times
so i'm i'm very uncomfortable about it
and i would like a bit of clarification
um from the officer i know it was
mentioned by councillor pasmore and
councillor miller about the time frame
that would might go into the section 106
if you could clarify that
and also if other members are minded to
approve um could we just also add in
the it does mention estate roads and
footpaths in the
um conditions but um
that there isn't a clear thing about the
actual footpath link
to the footpath that is to the west of
the site
so if that could just be east sorry i'll
just come
the east of the site so if that could
just be confirmed but i'm i'm
i am remain uncomfortable about the
school situation thank you
thank you very much uh yes case officer
please
apologize mandy if you could take us to
um slide 15 i'm
conscious that okay
let's do it this way then councilor
mansell you have that outstanding
question and
councillor even you've just raised it
again about the footpath so let me take
you to the
slide 15.
do you see in the bottom right hand
corner the purple
arrow that is connection to public
footpath
it is safeguarded on that that drawing
um there wouldn't be an issue if members
were
absolutely wanting belt and braces to
have a condition that says this scheme
shall make
a connection to that footpath i mean
that would give you
absolute cast iron guarantee the layout
actually does provide it
but let's be let's make sure
and in terms of points raised by if i
major
counselor geek referring to a number of
slides
that is the slide counselor geek that we
could
use as our basis for the condition for
the mix
and this is the sort of thing we can do
by conditioning words
rather than perhaps drawing to safeguard
that area for bungalows
we can prescribe generally the location
for the affordable housing which i think
members did feel was worthwhile so i'm
absolutely happy that
the insistence from councillor geek
around
let's see some of that detail we can
condition and in terms of your point
councillor you burn around
time scales
i'm not here to argue education policy
but what i can say i agree with
councillors who said
education policy and new schools can
take time
new development often takes five six
seven years to be completed
i would er on the side of caution and
let's say
there is a 15-year period within which
the county council can call on that
land for education purposes if the
county council
in that period decides definitively it
doesn't want it
then i think you would have to have a
clause that says in the event that it is
formally declined
ahead of 15 years it gets handed back
but i think we should keep it open for
as long as we can because
of the vicissitudes of educational
thinking i don't know whether gemma
you're
okay yeah thank you um i think that
would be it is if you have 15 years it
gives us the maximum option for that to
be taken up
um and the availability and that's what
i would say about the school on this
side
it's a bit like vince touched on with
the public open space
we've got to look to mitigate this site
i appreciate the concerns about the
schools elsewhere and the mix and
how people get there but we're talking
have we got educational mitigation for
these 40
now it seems to me we're securing the
land and we're doing that for 15 years
county have then said if it is a school
expansion we'll also get still from this
site towards school provision
and in any case if we don't get seal
we'll also have some money for new
school
in any case so for me those three things
do mitigate the education provision for
this specific site
and i appreciate all the points of
concern but we do have to look at
what this site is proposing and the
mitigation for this site unfortunately
not
more widely does that help thank you
thank you okay so i'm going to go back
oh yeah
councilman
thanks [ __ ] um i'm largely in agreement
with um my
colleagues who spoke earlier in the
front row
i think this is a reasonable sight it is
disappointing
that at county level the the education
um
requirements seem to be so fluid and
and need to be defined but i think we're
countering that and to a certain extent
carrying the county by
having to put the 15 years in and
perhaps that message could be taken back
by those who
who serve on both bodies that we as a
district council
would welcome more clarity around
education in our district
um as i come from a ward with no with
only one
very small school um i envy
all pit in the fact they may have an
extension to one and a building of
another
one small point about affordable
location of affordable housing
whilst i support the need for that
affordable housing to be
spread throughout the development i
would not wish to
tie the hands of the developers by
specifying the locations
a better design may come forward but if
we've specified where affordable housing
has to be we may derail that design
so i would be more comfortable with
saying that affordable housing should
be spread throughout the development
rather than
telling the developer where he's got to
put specific houses
thank you okay well
we've had a proposal from councilman
second by council pass more now the
question is how do you want to deal with
that last point
about the locations of the affordable
housing
thank you chair now i do take uh
councillor mayor's point on that
um and if um counselor parsons said
but not the location is what we're
saying yes that that i'll be happy with
that yes
exactly so thanks so much i think um
councillor
mayer's point was the condition ought to
require it to be distributed across
because what we normally we try and do
is avoid a single
hub so we could do that substantially in
accordance with and
a even distribution or some
similar good so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to ask you to run
through please all the new
recommendations that are now before us
whoever's going to do that gemma
and just check we've got everything that
everyone wants included because clearly
this is
there's a lot there no that's fine so i
think we are looking at the
recommendation on page 36
but with the update on page 11 of the
tabled papers in terms of the section
106.
good not from vince and then the
additional con sorry
and as part of that we're looking at the
time scale for the land
to be for 15 years availability
and then in terms of additional
conditions we're looking at condition to
restrict the residential use areas so
they can't
build on that agricultural the extra
land
um later that it that's separate
then we're agreeing the mix and that's
to be agreed
that we're limiting the story heights to
two story
that we're securing the specific
bungalow locations
so that they are in those locations
adjacent to the heathrow properties
and that we are agreeing the number and
distribution of affordable housing
i think that captures that point that
we're removing permitted development
rights
that we are putting a condition that
service runs to be agreed where these
could prejudice the retention of the
trees
and the southern footpath shall be
provided to link into the public right
of way
that is on there i think if i just bear
with me two seconds
i thought i spotted that one did
the one two three fourth bullet point
out from the bottom the state road and
footpath is is in the recommendation
castlefield the bit about essentially in
in line with the indicative plan did i
miss that in your list i
might not be listening carefully it
wasn't because it's in the
recommendations so uh
reserve matters the second will appoint
reserve matters to be submitted in
accordance with the submitted parameters
plan
so that's already there i was just
running through the action that's fine
thank you
jimmy your reference to parameters plan
i think
the committee would rather that was the
indicative layout
because the parameters plan is just a
series of arrows
so so the other update then is that
instead of um
on bullet two the parameters plan that
we're relating it to the indicator plan
is that correct it'd be a straight swap
events not both
okay good so i think on that basis are
we yes councilor madison
yeah two uh the um the biodiversity
and um ecology items
the the in the middle of the conditions
there um
this year two questions can we make the
um the enhancement strategy etc
come forward concurrent with reserve
matters i think we started to do that
um just one word there and also whether
any anything else emerged from this
october 2019
if you were able to find it yeah i don't
think that's a problem if members are
making the recommendation i'm happy that
the biodiversity of concurrent with
reserve matters
and the recommendations from october
2017 i think was the proposed conditions
that the
ecologist recommends are that it's
in accordance with the preliminary
ecological appraisal which as far as i
can see is in the recommendation
that we have a landscape and ecological
management plan again already in the
recommendation
that we have a biodiversity enhancement
strategy which we've just referenced
a badger method statement again that's
included
and finally a wildlife sensitive
lighting design scheme which again i
think that's included so i believe all
of those points that the ecologist
initially required are in the
recommendation thank you very much
so we on that basis we'll go to a vote
now
robert you're not going to type all of
that into
modern.gov but over to you
chair rather than disappointing you i
already have
so it's all there for members so if
you're happy for me to take through the
vote i will do that now yes please
so if members can please go to the
modern.gov app and go to today's agenda
and go to the plus sign on the top right
hand corner
for today's meeting from that you will
get the subsection on a vote voting and
attendance
and there you will see the line in a
light blue color
showing how to vote so if
i'm a bit worried about mixed tba i
thought the mix was part of the
condition
not to be arranged tba means to me to be
i believe it's to be agreed isn't it
gemma that's the
i thought the mix had been agreed and it
was the mix on the slide that
um mr pearce showed us sorry that's my
fault i have put down a slide 18 but i
wrote i wrote to be agreed to slide 18
that was that was the intention is that
it would be out of that slide
as per have you got a plan for that
specifically vince
yes so we can have as per the plan
fine so my mistake so as as the plan
i'll make the note of that one
thank you chair so with that in mind um
so
counselor passmore could i take your
vote please
four thank you very much and councillor
hicks
thank you very much
sorry i'm just waiting on one vote sure
give your answer verbally if you want
so chair taking those votes so it
comes to five votes four
and two against
with councillor mansell not voting as
she's thought
thank you chair good thank you very much
now we always say after 90 minutes we
should have a break
but it breaks more complicated today
than
obviously normal so we will have a quick
10 minute break for people that
want to go but please be very mindful of
the social distancing rules
as you use the facilities and we will
start again at 10 past
thank you
okay welcome back everyone uh so we move
on to the next planning application
which is dc20587 in great britain
business park
uh and we now hand over to the case
officer katherine hale to introduce the
application over to you catherine
thank you chair and good morning members
so before you have
an application a full planning
application for a change of use
of land to allow for the sighting of up
to
73 mobile homes um following the
demolition
of the existing buildings on site
so this is obviously great bright set in
context with the surrounding area you
can see watershed to the north
west and barkington north east
this is a site location plan so above
the
site to the north is an existing mobile
home park
to the east and south of the site is
mostly agricultural land as well as a
few dwellings
watershed field base is to the north
west
so this just shows the aerial map view
puts in a bit more context obviously
with
the surrounding development and
particularly the existing site to the
north
constraints wise the site is pretty much
unconstrained there is a footpath
running out along the outside of a site
but it doesn't
fall within the redline site plan
these are just two aerial images to show
the existing nissan huts which are on
site
these are situated to the rear of the
site and i'll see
if this application is approved these
would it be demolished to allow for the
sighting of the mobile homes
this is a proposed site layout so in
terms
of you know what we're looking at the
principle is
that the site already benefits from an
existing
extant outline planning permission um
this was granted in 2020
um for up to 51. it was outlined
so the number could technically change
it could be lower
but this slide shows the existing site
load well the proposed site layout plan
in terms of mobile homes on the left and
then you've got the
indicative site layout plan for the
dwellings that have been granted
on the right to show that they're you
know they're within the same site and
they also go down
to to front the road but it's considered
that as percy or
committee documents that the principle
of development in this area has been
established
by this extant con consent and therefore
actually you know the principle of
erecting up to 73 mobile homes on the
site is considered acceptable
so in terms of accessibility and
location whilst it is out
set outside the settlement boundary it
is considered to be connected
whilst it's acknowledged there will be
some reliance on the you know
private motor car there are bus routes
and it is well connected as
per a previous outline established
this is just to show the bus stops are
nearby
and part of the conditioned or section
106
should members be minded to go with a
recommendation
is to secure a footpath to the bus stops
so the at the moment we've got floods
and water with a holding objection
in terms of surface water drainage they
have a few issues
and we have tried to resolve it prior to
coming to committee
however um there hasn't been sufficient
time but these can be conditioned
and these can be a prior to commencement
condition
in terms of strategic housing because
this site
is for up to 73 mobile homes
they're considered in the same instance
with
normal residential dwellings for
affordable homes strategic housing
um aren't requiring obviously any
affordable home provision
in terms of mobile um caravans or static
homes
but they are seeking a commuted sum some
as of late yesterday afternoon and today
the commuted sum hasn't been agreed and
strategic housing are standing by their
original response which is outlined in
the papers before you
that they're seeking a commuted sum for
this scheme
so this would be secured um should we go
with our
my recommendation which is for the grant
of planning permission this should be
secured via section 106.
so yeah but that's that's the scheme
yeah the aerial photograph
the access is off of the the main road
to the you can see here down to the
south
so the road basically goes here from the
nissan huts around and down and onto the
main road here
no it's fine it is it's pound hill
all right
the raiders pound hill have we got
a better map that can show us where it
is
in relation
so the the the village of great bryce it
is further
south terrible trouble hearing
uh but there's the noise of the papers
the noise of the air conditioning
um and
all right is that better yeah okay i'll
just uh hover over it
so to the northwest i'll try and get the
pointer up again
this is obviously waterstream airfield
base is over here and you've got the
cluster of dwellings for that
ringshaw is slightly further to the
northeast and great price
is further down to the south off this
road
i think i've only got one very far out
which was at the start
so going back to the access
the access for all the 71 or 73
73 is through that
entrance onto that road and that single
that single access point is enough for
140
odd cars yep suffolk county council
highways have been consulted and they're
happy
with the proposal and they believe it
meets the requirements or see subject to
conditions and it's in a 30 mile zone
anyway
because it's an existing business park
the the site access and the road is
is wider than it looks on the plans
so the junction into the site is is wide
enough for obviously
vehicles to enter and exit at the same
time
other questions the case officer please
yeah councillor muller first then mayor
thank you chair uh catherine you
outlined a number of bus routes
uh close to this particular site how
frequent
are the actual buses to this area please
thank you they it obviously it depends
on
you know how you interpret frequent they
aren't
every hour as such but there's enough
for people to get to
places such as stone market and favorite
field without
soul reliance on to you know private
motor vehicles
sorry could you just point out where is
the bus stop on them
so you can see up here this is the
existing park and
here are venison huts and the site would
go down here this is the entrance
onto the site so there's bus stop here
and a further
a few bus stops down here thank you uh
okay i've got a whole
swath of hand so i'll just go along
castle miller next
sorry counselling there sorry thanks
chief can you bring up the outline
um planning permission that's all in
place please
yeah that's fine
all right that outline is only
indicative
um the current full application
seems to differ from that outline which
is an indicative plan and the existing
that the caravans won't have any
personal space
they'll have um limited sort of space
around
the caravans but not per se the the
with this application it's solely the
principle that we're really looking at
the actual
the layout um and almost design of the
the carry-ons or mobile homes are
actually determined by licensing
under the caravan caravanning and
campsite act
um hence why we've not obviously got any
elevational drawings that's a
separate entity it ends up being the
principle that although it's a full
application we're not actually concerned
with layout
because it's a caravan site yeah yeah
just for permanent residential use
that element is dealt with under the
licensing can i ask a follow-on from
that then
are we talking about a number that is
too much
could we say a number of 73 is too much
i think i think we could yeah yeah
yeah definitely thank you uh okay
counselor
uh mansell you were next uh thank you
um could you well i've got a couple of
questions firstly could you clarify the
the situation about the um parking
spaces
proposed for each unit which is
mentioned in paragraph
5.2 on page 117 could you also clarify
the fact that because this is a caravan
park we don't need any
public open space and also i notice
on the planning portal um that the most
up-to-date drawing on the portal on the
9th
of march is for 69 units
not for 73 so could you comment on
why there's a a layout with 69 when
we're being asked now
to allow up to 73 thank you
um so taking rose in turn in terms of
the
highway provision or the car parking
provision obviously county council
highways have
looked at the plans and they're happy
with the amount of
parking spaces um i believe that because
they're not
residential dwellings in the usual sense
the
parking guidance is slightly different
and that the
each one having one parking provision is
considered acceptable in this instance
um and then with regards to
um the number i i hadn't
obviously there's no error on my part i
you know assume there was
up to 73 and presumably you know
here before you can decide whether the
69 that's shown
are more appropriate than the 73 but
it's that leeway of when you're
considering up to
it can i say it can vary i presume
because of the campsite and
caravan and campsite act again
that allows potentially for fewer
caravans but
if we redeem this acceptable and grant
permission
we couldn't have any they couldn't have
any more than 73 it's more of a
the maximum i believe do you want to
come in trimmer on that because i think
we need to be clear what's before
69 or 73. yep so obviously the
description is for 73. perhaps catherine
would you just have a quick check on the
plan of how many is actually on there
for us
essentially it's a bit like the outline
situation which is if we think 73 is
acceptable
then that's what we're determining in
front of us but we do need the plan to
essentially match up to that
if you think less would be appropriate
then there are a
manner of choices before you we could
refuse because we think that 73 is
unacceptable
or we could potentially defer because we
think it's a few less and we're not
quite there
so that would be a probably an option
for debate but essentially we should be
looking at 73
but i would just like to confirm that we
have got a plan and that the plans we
are all looking at have got
that number on there
i i i haven't had a response about the
public open space
yet um but i'm sorry i read
section 5.2 is the highways authority
not making comment that's not the same
as um
be approving it uh they they make no
comment regarding the proposal
so that doesn't quite tell you what you
said but can we have an answer about the
lack of public open space
again it goes down to the
the way that the the mobile home site is
is looked at and considered is this is a
principle
of you know of the change of use and
whether mobile homes would be
appropriate
as opposed to um you know
the layout which usually comes with a
public open space but there's
i don't i'd have to check with gemma but
i don't think there's anything to say
that we couldn't
ask for potentially public open space in
a section 106
agreement i'm not entirely sure on that
one
so it's it's different from the houses
that we've been looking at that they've
got the consent for on the site
in that they obviously don't each come
with their own garden land they are part
of a wider site
so the understanding is that as you step
out of one of these you are in
some form of open space hence the slight
differentiation between the two
matters that in a house
you've got your private garden land and
obviously if we don't provide that where
do you go
in a flat for example we might then
expect public open space but because of
the
way this is it is in its own space
whether you consider that sufficient or
whether you would like something like an
area for play
or some more wide open space
park type provision
would be something we could look at as
to whether there's capacity or as
catherine says through securing that as
part of the 106 that they will provide
a scheme for some open space and then we
will agree that
um so there is that it is very different
from how we normally deal with houses
does that help on the open space point
we'll come back to it in debate i
suspect
can i just ask how many parking spaces
there are on site
for the amount of homes with the extra
do we have a figure
yeah so i was just counting the other
ones can i have a moment to just
do a math well i can ask the applicant
okay so moving on cancer matheson you're
next
thank you yeah first like to help on the
matter of the um bus services if we
could have a look at the um
there is a slide isn't that of of um
where the buses are coming from and so
on
what i wanted to let's wait for it to
appear
yep gone past it that's that one that's
right
so the
is are we saying that the the bus
service
because four six one four six two they
actually go between stone market and
hadley
and they go through my ward the village
of great finbra
and my current understanding is is that
the
the scheduled service is is down to
um two days a week
and but it's erratically running
not managing to do that at the moment um
so i i think the um you know that we
should not
overstate the idea that there's a bus
service i'm not familiar with what the
one one once bus does
but i suspect it isn't tremendously
frequent either
um that that's that's on the on the
buses
and the other the other point is
paragraph 4.3
talking about the the um
the shop and the post office closing uh
they wrote on the uh on the air base
um but the public house is the subject
of a current
redevelopment application now my
understanding is that it was the subject
of a change of use application
but that this has been refused unless
i'm
sorely mistaken so rather officers could
just help us
understand what's what's happened there
yeah no so the application for the
pub it was the red lion in great brit
and
it was as you've rightly said it was a
change of use into
a residential dwelling it was refused
um earlier this year i think potentially
a month ago
maybe or a couple of weeks ago um
obviously the agent has a right to an
applicant has a right to appeal
so it's not to say it won't go from a
pub to a house it's
you know we've made our decision it's
down to the plum spectra if if
an appeal comes in as far as i'm aware
we haven't had an appeal
yet um and i i would assume
that given the current restrictions
lifting for
covid that potentially the pub is is
opening
again as a a pub but i don't i don't
know that exactly
that's
thank you chair um i was going to ask
about open space as well so thank you
for
clarifying that but also landscaping um
there doesn't seem to be much
landscaping on
on site i just wondered if you could
clarify that please and also there's a
seems to be a great deficit in health
provision um could you
kind of give any opinion on the
likelihood of um
if civil funds are forthcoming that that
will actually meet
the potential demand from this site
thank you jim
so again the the landscaping it falls
down to
um the campsite and caravan campsite act
as opposed to this actual application i
believe the agent's with us today so we
could potentially see
um direct post questions to him later on
to see if there's a way to get
more landscaping in um i imagine we
could probably still
condition it gemma's nodding so
if that's what we'd like to see um
should you go with a recommendation then
we can obviously condition
landscape plans to be submitted and and
so on
um with regards to the healthcare um
i believe there is a seal contribution
just need to check
yeah we might just need a second to
check on that because it's about built
floor space and the definition of it
yeah whether a technical i mean
we'll have a look but in theory either
it's built floor space and it
contributes
it may fall out of the definition of
built floor space but that's not to say
under the
wider sill fund that if the nhs applied
for more funding here
it would come out of the pot so it isn't
either or but i can check the detail if
you'd like
thanks so close just a couple of
follow-up can i just be just asked just
for
absolute clarity so how many of these
are two bedroom
versus one bedroom how many car parking
spaces are there total for the 73
locations and how many visitor car
parking spaces are there
and can you just give absolute clarity
where all the rain water foul water and
sewage from the 73 properties is going
to actually go
and be dealt with just just just um
clear yeah
so um there's not any proposed one beds
there it's a mix of
two to three um i don't have the
specific information as to how many two
beds compared to how many free beds i do
have the
um the type the size of the units and
and how many of each size um
which may give an indication obviously
the larger unit most likely to be a free
bed
i'll ask the applicant for the detail on
that thank you yeah and the car parking
um i need to count unfortunately i can't
respond to the questions and also count
at the same time i'll miss the questions
so
i'm just thinking visitor parking do we
know how many visitor bays there are
um i don't believe there are any for the
site i think it's purely
one allocated space per mobile site home
right okay and where does all the sewage
go
from a minimum of 150 people living on
site
um i'll just double check there's
probably something for the
um applicant i am aware that obviously
floods
have still got holding up objection in
terms of surface water drainage
um which is something to bear in mind
so at the moment there's an objection
from the floods team at the county
council on surface water drainage
yeah that's correct right so if there's
an objection from the county council on
this
why is the recommendation for as it is
so we can go away and ask for the extra
information it's about the fact they
haven't updated their drainage strategy
to match some of it so it's not a
out and out no from county council it's
a we haven't got the information
so i think the the query had been
do they provide the information then
come to committee and it's a no
or actually can we come to committee
have that
decision from ourselves is this okay or
not if you are happy with it in
principle
you what i would suggest is we'll
delegate an authority to officers to go
and secure that
if it's not securable we'll look to
refuse it on the grounds as otherwise by
county floods
hopefully it will be securable we can
then go away add the conditions and go
through 106. so
it's more a matter of resolving it um
and often applicants do want you know
your decision on these things before
they
go and go through further kind of costs
to resolve that matter
thank you um
sorry to to mention the same query again
but
i've been delving deep deeper into the
planning
diagrams on the planning portal and i
believe
i i'm happy to be corrected but the plan
that we've got on page 178 of our papers
is the one that is labeled 69 dwellings
and i think there are 69 dwellings on it
i've looked further down the planning
portal and there is a superseded drawing
which claims it's got 73 units but
appears to only be
the units on the other side adjacent
side so we haven't actually got a
a an indicative layout of how they're
going to put 73 units
on this site could i have some
confirmation that i'm reading this
correctly
do we or do we not have an indicative
plan of how we're going to fit 73 units
on this site
if you can give me a few moments to
finish counting rather than trying to
answer the questions and i can come back
rather than
so that's okay
well i think i think what we'll do i
don't want i think what we'll do is
we'll
um have we got any other questions apart
from the size and the car parking
yes cancer passed on um chairman i i
don't know whether it's appropriate
and it is a question i'm just wondering
whether there seemed to be a lot of
loose ends hanging around here
and i'm a little bit uncomfortable is it
appropriate to defer it
that at this stage to be fair to
everybody involved that's my question
because i think there's an awful lot of
issues here that we need some
clarification
on and i'm not being critical to anybody
here it is a fairly significant
application i just wonder
to be fair to the applicant and
everybody on the committee and
everything else
is this the time to um make a suggestion
for a deferment
that's my personal i think what we'll do
is we'll yes
yeah exactly i think i think what we'll
do is we'll go through and hear from the
applicant because we've got to have the
opportunity to ask the applicant the
questions that we're all asking
and then at that point we'll decide if
we have enough information before us or
not
will be in my view thank you
okay
i've counted finally um yeah 69
um so can i just say if the
if on the basis of what's been presented
to this committee and on the basis of
what's before us in the papers is
showing 69
but we are told the applications for 73
we're being asked to make a decision on
papers that are not accurate
so therefore we will have to defer the
application is my opinion
because we haven't got the correct
papers
all right thank you chairman um just i'm
as a little disadvantaged myself because
i've got i.t
problems which mr carmichael's done his
best to help me with the spare computer
but
if i can ask my colleague this is an
application for a
change of use so it's for stationing of
not for operational development it's for
the use of land for the stationary
mobile homes yes the change of use for
stationing of up to 73. so it's not
quite the same as do we know how many
houses they want to build
and or at least up to but it's still it
is obviously still an important point
um it goes without saying so i think if
um
but i think my point would be where we'd
normally get to an outline which if you
can't demonstrate that we could put them
on there
that makes it more difficult to make
decisions if we had a lot more spare
space
i'd probably be saying look there are
other options
the the plan on slide six in the papers
doesn't seem to me like there is
extra space where there'd be flexibility
so i would have
concerned whether we could do it and and
therefore i'll be tending to agree that
we should have a plan that shows that
but would that you
can i switch on again yes thank you uh
through you chairman i think jem has hit
the nail on the head if
it would be as long as we we could be
reasonably satisfied in making a
decision that that number could be
accommodated
on the site that would be fair enough
and it would be a bit unfortunate if
there was some confusion between
different drawings but if as gemma says
there appears to be a cause for concern
that we we've got a plan with 69 on and
no more space
but i mean
sorry john my feeling is that as it's
just been said we've got a map in front
of us showing 69 dwellings
the application is for 74. there's
nowhere before us where you can
obviously fit in another
then the up to get it up to that number
i think therefore and the papers only
show
60 don't show the full amount i'm not
comfortable making a decision today
when we haven't got all the information
before us i now don't think based on
that information i don't think there's
any point taking it any further it would
be my
view so i'm going to propose that this
is deferred
and come back to another meeting uh
based on the information that's been
presented the fact that we haven't got
accurate
a map and accurate detail in front of us
of what's being applied for
all those in favour
chairs sorry we need a second down then
before yeah oh sorry who would second
that
and we're going to have the electronic
and we do it electronically
while while um mr carmichael's uh
sorting out a voting slip for us
um i don't think we ever got to the
bottom of the um
foul foul drainage question that you put
i mean i i got a feeling
i saw that it was not going to be
connected it was going to be
an on-site but i can't find that note
anywhere so
i believe that and that's what officer
springback
just
could we point out there are some other
details as well like the bus
service yeah so i think you've heard
what's what i was going to suggest so
i'm
i'm thinking so we've got the let me
score this downstairs we've got the bus
service query
you'd also like to know about the um car
parking
spaces hold on
and perhaps what our licensing caravan
licensing people would do what their
attitudes are because i know there are
sites in my
district ward which are park homes and
for instance parking is a problem people
who live in park homes
sometimes they both have a car and
sometimes they have visitors believe it
or not
and it is a continuous problem so one
would like perhaps to know what that
department
is intending to do and built on that
point
we need to know the number of two
bedroom and three bedrooms because
that's going to help determine the point
jones has made
there's a comment here about the
distance to the school i have no idea
whether it's
50 yards across muddy fields or five
kilometers across muddy field
so i've got the bus service car parking
and visitor spaces
the flooding issue from county floods to
be confirmed some more information
services in terms of fair water drainage
and the number of bedrooms
likely i think bedrooms might be a
slightly more difficult one because it
is a sighting of them but i think we can
at least give a
more information hopefully from some of
the details would we not sometimes
condition
x number of two x number of three so we
need to
know that to understand how to condition
it yeah
and open space and landscaping okay okay
robert over to you
thank you chair so i have on my list
just to double check for gemma just
across reference very briefly
um to defer the application to receive
in to to seek further accurate
information on the application with
regards
to the indicative plan details of bus
routes details of parking spaces
details of on floods and drainage and
details on open space and landscaping is
that everything
okay thank you very much so members
if you could please go to the modern.gov
app and go to the vote in the top
right hand go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner and go
to the attendance voting tab if you
click on the voting tab it will take you
to today's vote that's in progression in
the light blue color
you may need to scroll down the page i
will now take
the part did i miss proposal and
secondary uh so we had council hicks
propose
and then council partners thank you
sorry
now confirm that all votes have been
received and that is a unanimous vote to
defer the application
okay we don't like to defer because we
obviously we've all gathered to make a
decision
so i know the applicants come here but
we do like to get all the information to
make that decision so
thank you for joining us the next item
on the agenda is do we have any site
inspections or requests that need to be
reported to the committee
none requested chair we closed the
meeting at 11 43
and thank you for all coming back for
council training today it's lovely to
see everyone's faces again